action scenes at the top too the action
scenes at the top are definitely more
like ben affleck asking
yeah yeah i was badass he was sitting
here going like damn eat gerard now
robert pence
you're so so corny eat your heart out
robert
that was very important
what's going on reject nation we are
going to watch today from an awesome
youtube channel called
bat in the sun this short film crowd
funded by a big crowd
batman dying is easy we got tagged on
social media like you guys gotta
cover this i made sure to contact bat in
the sun over on twitter
i asked them hey is it cool if i just
re-upload your video without us reacting
to it could i just take the credit
for this video and they said no but you
can do a reaction to it and i said fine
bottom line we have permission to do a
reaction to it and add
commentary thanks bad in the sun
let's watch it no i'm really excited for
it i'm really excited it's gonna be
awesome and one day they will make a
batman live-action movie or do something
hbo max
for now
such a cool logo even
yes
what i love about the designs that i've
seen tees are like they're
they seem to be like a hybrid of a whole
bunch of different batman like animated
series
the dark knight trilogy even the dceu
it's the snyders
you can just see it right here in the
logos and such
[Music]
gotham city
my man
hell yeah
hell yeah
howie
oh
never again
[Applause]
that yellow hatter
[Music]
oh it's intimacy hey
oh crap alfred where are you you want to
be my psychic
the iceberg or is that cassandra kane
i was wondering
it's less racist if you say
[Music]
i had actual things to do three of my
men are missing you
you know what i'm gonna find out where
they are one way or another
i don't really have a knife that's your
time
the babysitter freak in a cave
flying around the city pretend to be a
superhero
you know just because gordon respects
you doesn't mean i have to right
it goes both ways
this looks so cool i know
the face-to-face clown
is uh
well uh he's demanding to see you of
course
you guys spend most of your life
together right
i thought maybe you'd be excited
celebration from your side of things
no as far as i'm concerned one of you
madness dwellers
is eating exactly what you deserve death
of a joker nothing to celebrate
all i'm saying is that somebody
should pull the trigger on him a long
time ago
you're the one with a gun you have a
license to kill
this
it's definitely got the frank miller
vibes too
dude michael matson could play bullock
in his sleep i know
it's his default character
listen i thought it told me
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he sounds like kevin conroy has the face
of michael keaton
and this like edge of like the ben
affleck
yeah and he's like so naturally like
built like
uh no yeah it's jacked it's like the
batman animated series version
god this could be a tv show
damn props to your location scouting
like this really could be a tv show look
at this this is incredible this is
absolutely incredible
this is dr hugo strange this
announcement is regarding tonight's
schedule
due to a code b27 dinner
and all night activities
that guy looks so familiar i know
yo is that doug jones it is doug jones
oh he's the riddler everyone else uses
it
oh
hi there this is so cool
[Music]
[Music]
hello
looks amazing
what a long walk to the joker i don't
got to walk through the whole asylum to
this guy
i bet this joker has something to do
with that
i bet the joker has something to do with
that
this moment is supposed to take place on
the gotham bridge
of the old water reserve our jerry's
abandoned circus
a televised for millions to see
it wasn't supposed to end like you want
we first met
with all my close calls
skin cancer the humor is not
lost on me i guess dying is easy
yeah and comedy is hard why not
it must be epic it must be
gut-wrenching
you have nothing to say i just told you
that i'm dying
this is it the final confrontation after
all we've been through
this is our final soliloquy
i don't care about our legacy
bye
won't kill me because you're afraid
not because of some high moral code or
your
one rule it's because without me
you can't justify your own existence
you're right i am afraid i'm afraid of
myself
that once i murder i'll like the taste
of it and then i'll kill
every single inmate
i want to see that yeah prison fight
poison ivy has her environmental cause
riddler has his puzzles
with you you have nothing
without me you become your worst fear
and that's being upstaged by everyone
here i am the king
of this asylum see my crown
sparkles in the bitter glow of twilight
he's like it's like mark hamill and
jack nicholson combined
you've spent your whole life fighting
and crying
and after night dead sidekick
you have to dead sidekick and for what
you're utterly miserable
afraid of the one thing that could
possibly
bring you joy see
i am completely and genuinely
happy i wake up every morning
with a great big smile i
absolutely love my life
but you
absolutely hate oh he's pushing he's
pulling he's pulling
i've often wondered where were you
when the boy lanes bleeding out
where are you
true presenting him to me was a stroke
of genius
masterful in your story writing oh and i
have to give the boy
credit he knew how to sell it
his firm must be the body
breaking under the weight of my lead
crowbar
do you know what his last words were
with his last breath
what he said i'll come back as a redhead
did hear the boy scream your name
look at the shading of it's all dark now
moving on
you not remember yes about the snack
it was her hair
[Music]
the accumulation of everyone in this
asylum
do it just for a little bit just for
like
like three
[Music]
little flock seconds his own and barbara
her dreams chatted like her spine
oh
but all old i hear dance
you're no longer relevant when's the
last time that you've been in the news
even condiment king have had their
headlines
good job condoming
[Music]
um
i can't tell you how much of a choice
joker man
i knew
what are you talking about i faked your
toxicology report
oh cool
look at me i'm sick i've been poisoning
your water supply for weeks
i knew that if you thought
i discovered that one of jarvis's thugs
had possession of a police officer
detective batman i found three sets of
fingerprints
and one of them was yours
[Laughter]
is that a joke
[Music]
so the next time the joker's actually
really sick aren't they like no batman's
just faking it
[Laughter]
it'll take him days to fight his actual
dead body
he's not really dead batman just did
that definitely he's just playing
all right good job
can you imagine what these guys could do
with an actual like
real television budget yeah and not
crowdfunding and their own money
you know yeah with literal millions
i think i was too stupid to sell it
i wish i could have saved the man at the
time
those men were already dead
excuse me what was that
what'd you just say i said they were
already dead
you knew they were there yes
what was all that about why did you do
all that for them
i didn't do it for them i did it for
their families
i had to take away hope so their
families could heal
it's said that the worst thing to come
out of pandora's box
were not the sorrows or the plagues
it was hope itself hope hopes a gamble
hope lacks certainty in this city knows
all too well what hopelessness
and pain can do the germs of man
now without hope maybe the family can
start the healing process and move on
he's a heartless bastard too too crazy
to deal with
and i realized now i like that halloween
costume
is he not such a bad guy at all
an [ __ ]
i heard that
i don't know what it's like to get to
acceptance and grief though
do this all for my parents that i never
got over here
not knowing why my parents have left me
with this endless open wound
an abyss that i stare into
gotham gazette
[Applause]
that was great guys bravo that was great
wow
kevin porter
oh the writer director co-director
played him cool
good for him yes doug jones
got that right who is hugo strange
chris dodger the singer
that's how i know that i do know him for
having the chrome dome and the beard
dang all right you play joker i'll do
the music
fairtrade
[Laughter]
[Music]
and i'll do the sound design but i'm
editing it yeah
we'll produce it again we're doing the
brothers conversation
gosh man
[Music]
jamie costa that's sort of the obi-wan
the deep fakes and stuff yeah
amy johnson is she this i think she was
the stunt
she was someone who was on quarter crew
once that woman i feel like she might
have been
like harley quinn yeah
the poison ivy look kind of familiar too
but i didn't catch she had some actual
names on here
yeah yeah man that crowd funding coming
through
that's right yeah
this is such a lovely piece of music
[Music]
we should do crowdfunding for our little
sketches we should we need 100.
can you help us think about the stretch
goals
six thousand dollars we can add
characters
multiple locations
we could hire a third person or a third
person to help
us do this
yeah we should start doing that it's
easier to crowdfund oh sean
is uh uh a woman
die this is ruiner
okay oh the music and stuff all right
all right all right all right
i did not mean to impersonate matthew
mcconaughey
no idea who this
storm that's a sexy costume
miss kyle
[Music]
uh
oh dang let's do this
stay tuned for the very sexy follow
hey man this is the direction we have
yet to go with it i think if they had a
show it would be pretty cool to get like
a
a a random uh thank you to everyone here
who's being listed oh man i think it'd
be cool if they did uh
if they did have their own show that if
you had like one of your bottle episodes
of just
one hour selena and bruce on the roof
and you just watch like what happens
watch all that sexual tension
no more than that you know the conflicts
the conversations
mix in with sexual interactions
that are all shot like a 300 yeah you
get the director of malcolm and marie to
do it
in that episode i love the idea of a
bottle episode
set in a bottle that's just the rooftop
of something
it's like the biggest bottle conceivable
good dad in the sun that in the sun that
was amazing
a plus plus plus yeah that was
seriously an amazing job it was amazing
yeah i hope these guys are able to get a
tv show one day can't imagine the
pressure of having to
write and direct and also play the joker
like everything have to know everything
in and out like how do you focus on even
directing a scene when you're the joker
i mean it's not the best choice of words
to be like playing batman's easier i
wouldn't say
playing batman is easier something with
batman that's
interesting is if you're especially if
you're doing like a fan made film is if
you're doing an
embodiment of prior batman's people
could be like
yeah with joker you want to see
something
definitely different every time which is
kind of the weird dichotomy you guys
like
you want them to not do an impersonation
of someone whereas like this batman i
thought that there was certain rhythm
rhythmic lines that would
certainly felt different and i felt like
he was this kind of cool clash
of like kevin kahn roy michael keaton
and ben affleck
all like messing away even some
christian bail it was like all the
live-action batman mix with
the kevin conroy voice and i love that
and i i i feel like his presence was so
imposing so
i don't want to act like his you know it
wasn't a unique performance it certainly
was
just with joker i think there's a little
there's there tends to be more eyes on
what's the what's the different thing
they're gonna do and i thought it was
interesting kind of this like
because he's supposed to be ill under
the weather yeah
you know it's like why he's got the eye
fro down and he did remind me of like a
mix of
mark hamill and jack nicholson it seemed
to be kind of this like inward
expression with his body language like
his arms are always like kind of
here you know and this this rhythm
with his words was kind of like this
pacing you know yeah it is sickly is a
good word almost like gollum-esque
yeah you know like a gollum-esque lift
and his cadence to it yeah and i thought
it was i thought it was unique you know
like you get the bat like this is the
live action batman tv show version i
would love to watch i gotta be i'd be so
addicted to this i love that you never
actually see him as bruce wayne in this
short film
like it feels very like a contain not i
don't know if it contains the right word
but it's
very specific the story we are telling
here
and also you know like a cool chance at
world building of
selling people online i keep talking
about them getting a tv show and i don't
know what the big goal of it
is it just feels like they could do a tv
show oh absolutely i mean it seems like
each of these cells is a potential
episode waiting to happen and i mean the
writing level with the way that they
went back and forth between batman the
motivations of this
entire meeting in general the twists and
turns like imagine
what they could do with you know that
level of writing we saw here but with
these various other characters and
whatnot you know
yeah i think they have a great handle on
tone
and pace the music i thought
was wonderful like did they shoot this
in la i can't tell where they
couldn't tell either and i know some of
that exterior stuff must have been
composited and cg together but it was
really convincing for the most part and
yeah some of those interiors
looked like places that you could see
downtown some of those exterior
like the rooftop shops were starting to
look like downtown l.a to me
i don't know i mean it's like the only
one i could ever really define is that's
definitely new york city but you know
yeah but when they do like hop around
between chicago or
canada or l.a i'm like not sure which
one this is
yeah totally some of those like over
shoulder down into like a busy city
street shots that looked
clearly like they were in camera like
yeah those could have been l.a
but the the aesthetic of what gotham
looked like had this really cool
hodgepodge
where it wasn't so much like the dark
knight where it just feels like they
shot it in chicago
yeah and they had like a yellow
cinematography tint too
yeah you know and it wasn't like to the
extreme of like a tim burton
movie you know but it did have the mix
of feeling like a real city
it was kind of more akin to i'd say
actually the gotham tv show like i
really love that series i found that
very underrated and it felt more like
that word so you got a little bit of
your animated flourishes here and there
with some of the the lighting and some
of what's being put in the background
but mainly it also feels like a real
city uh come to life but it still has
that
menace throughout but all those like
statue shots of batman on the rooftops
like dude this looks this looks straight
like a real thing
yeah like right down to like the way the
cape is hanging as he's staring out over
the city the lineup of gargoyles like
yeah
everything from the way they handle the
characters to the look
to yeah just the vibe of gotham city and
the asylum in general like it had so
much personality
even though the center piece of the
whole thing is this conversation between
joker and the batman
the bookends have so much life that it
really feels like you are
kind of living in and walking through
gotham city and uh yeah it's like props
to the
location managers too because it had
that perfect gotham equality where yeah
it doesn't feel too much like an exact
city i know it has that sort of
downtrodden
grim sort of under glow to it yeah
and yeah it's further enhanced by how
like i thought the building they chose
to be the asylum was gorgeous because it
has that perfectly sort of
gothic it's kind of old and not too run
down but you know it could be a lot in
better repair
everything came together in such a
professional looking way that yeah i
would love to see them tackle a huge
budget well the visual effects
and the practical effects of what they
did with all the characters they were
cutting around to in arkham asylum look
really freaking good like it looked
great
always keep in mind like this is not
funded by
warner brothers you know funded by you
yeah so having to do like a passion
project like this and to see how good it
turned out
is is so awesome and impressive and it
has so much nostalgia but also a lot of
refreshing new
qualities to it action scenes at the top
too the action scenes at the top were
definitely more like ben affleck asking
yeah yeah i was badass i was even
sitting here going like damn gerard now
robert pettis
you're so so corny eat your heart out
robert
that was very important
but in that moment i was like underneath
the bridge my ass let's get corny to
cringe
that's where i want to go yeah i mean
back to the ark of asylum though
that scene with batman and joker i mean
it's like yeah you're getting the
the references down of you know you got
jason todd being mentioned here you got
barbara gordon i actually
love the way that whole scene was done
it's like yes it's kind of
the traditional battle of ideologies and
philosophies of this yin and yang
situation of batman and joker going
toe-to-toe
so you pick up on joker's trying to push
him joker's provoking him to try to
do the final kill you see that you see
where that's going and then by the time
batman like had the chain around like
all right
as as as aggressively awesome as is
you're like yeah
batman's not gonna kill him you know
it's like that's probably what it's
gonna be like i won't kill him and i
won't give in to it
but then i was so impressed with what
the reveal was oh this was batman's plan
the whole time like i
i really didn't see that part of the
equation coming in
of batman had been setting this up in
order
it's because he's the one who's actually
pushing joker and words
joker was under the impression he was
pushing batman to have
that moment of you have all that [ __ ]
with barbara gordon being put on display
and batman being put into a rage after
that whole thing about jason todd and
freaking
barbara and then he's like oh screw you
joker and then to immediately go
oracle did you catch that that cathartic
rewarding feeling
of oh boy like we do joker was just
trying to talk [ __ ] on all that stuff he
did to barbara and
barbara's got him you know like it's so
it's so badass and i love that level of
like detective work
that batman is actually doing in here so
i think that this really captured that
the spirit of batman so well the
beginning with the
with the fight scenes and working
through the shadows you know was getting
into his batmobile from the bat cave and
working through the shadows and taking
on some bad guys and doing the fight
scenes but then being heroic the
philosophy
discussions and then of course having
the detective manipulation tactics that
he does
which was great one of the more
impressive ingredients to me actually
is the bullock portrayal uh from michael
madsen
who is uh just so natural for something
like this like you you hear
michael matson's book you're like oh
yeah no yeah
totally it's it's such a such an easy
association to make
one of my favorite portrayals of bullock
is actually from the gotham tv show
where he's not
just crooked cop like eventually becomes
like a
a really good guy i appreciated this of
like bullock is forced
into this position of having to work
with batman
just because gordon is hospitalized you
feel this thing of like resistance from
michael madsen's performance of
obviously he judges and doesn't like
batman but there's this side of him
underneath it's like maybe i should open
myself up to him or change my mind
especially in that final scene they had
i love that
complex layers like michael madison
easily could have just shown up and like
screw it
but but i felt like especially in that
final scene that michael madsen really
brought a real performance here
absolutely all right guys well
every aspect of this i thought was
awesome and impressive and i hope these
guys get a tv show if you haven't
subscribed to them do yourself a favor
subscribe to them show your support
if you watched it here for the first
time with our reaction
please go to their video and actually
watch it it deserves to be seen on
a full-size screen like this like this
full size screen right here
hit that like button check us out on
patreon as well
last but not least
scuba steve scuba my friend you know
what i'm thinking
i'm thinking of bringing back that whole
thing about you doing graffiti work
because you know who will do a great job
at doing graffiti work in gotham city
scuba steve you could be top-notch in
the gang of the like joker kills off a
lot of his henchmen but he would need
you
because in terms of doing like why so
serious
and the joker spray paints all over the
wall
all the neon colors and the mixtures and
stuff you're the guy for it
you'd be like no anyone could be killed
but scuba steve
you were an asset in the criminal
underworld that's what i'm trying to
tell you
you have a lot of value to bad guys
everywhere
to people who litter to people who
destroy buildings property damage you
are an essential ingredient to the
increasingly
non-stop homeless population that we
have in america today
you took the words right out of my mouth
until the end there